Each of the projects in this course has three deliverables. The source code,
involving, solving a specific problem in several ways,
a project report containing project specific content, and a design study report.
The design study represents an, the explicit knowledge about the design, that
you learned during the project. In summary, here are the expected sections to
be included in the design that are important. Section one includes the context.
That is the background, motivation and vocabulary.
Next section is the research questions. Then descriptions of the subjects,
experimental conditions and the variables, both independent and dependent.
Section six has the method. Then come the results, discussion and conclusions.